everyone
and welcome to today's simultaneous
cabinet meeting for the baber and
mid-suffolk cabinets
i just um quickly run through a few
opening
comments just to remind everyone that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
youtube
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the entirety of the meeting will be
filmed except for the confidential or
exempt items
if you attend the meeting in person you
will be consented to being filmed
that the images and sound recordings
could be used for webcasting training
purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
moving on to the agenda
we have first item apologies for absence
chair if i may could i do the opposite
and formally welcome councillor
hadingham to the cabinet for the first
time
her name doesn't appear on the papers so
um
if the roll call is taken from the
papers um she may be accidentally missed
off
so councillor hattingham has been an
exemplary chairman
of council for mid-suffolk and with
effect from
thursday night's full council meeting i
formally invited her to join the cabinet
and i'm pleased to say that she's here
now
as portfolio holder for counts for
housing
thank you chair thank you and uh and
i'll
extend my uh warmest welcome to council
hanging him as well
for baber i know we have apologies from
councillors halt and arthi
are there any other apologies from mid
suffolk
chair if i may can i run through a roll
call
uh so we're aware of which councillors
are here
certainly yes yeah thank you
okay so if you can um indicate your
presence when i call your names
please uh we have apologies from
councillor clive arfy
councillor busby here council davis
here councillor halt we have apologies
councillor melvisi here
councillor osborne here
councillor parker
president council award
president councillor brewster
president councillor byrne president
councillor flatman president councillor
fleming
president councillor gould president
councillor hattingham president
councillor morley present councillor
richardson
present and councillor whitehead uh
present
thank you chair thank you
and the next item declaration of
interests by councillors
are there any no okay moving on
and uh the next item to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
do we have any uh petitions
non-received chair thank you
uh next item questions by councillors uh
that that
do not relate to the uh matters uh items
on the agenda do we have any other
questions by councillors
non-received thank you
right moving on to item five matters
referred by the overview and scrutiny or
joint audit and standards committees
we have um a paper from the
overview and scrutiny committee and i
will hand over to
the to the joint chairs to introduce
this
firstly to councillor welum
thank you chair um on the 4th of
september
overview and scrutiny considered a
report from the
assistant director for environment and
commercial partnerships
committee praised officers for their
report
the joint overview and security
committee recommend
that the mid-suffolk public realm
service remain in-house
and have also recommended to baby
cabinet that the service in that
district
be brought in house and the service for
the two districts be managed by an
in-house team and the operational work
be carried out by an in-house labor
force
this way forward should be the most cost
effective method of operation
give the greatest flexibility it would
allow the range of services to broaden
and have scope for local councils taking
on some of the work
should they wish to do so overview and
scrutiny committee raised concerns
around resources
including staffing benefits pensions and
vehicles and equipment
also in regard to maintaining separate
accounts for each of the two districts
so that one of the districts didn't
subsidize the other
officers assured members of the
committee that these matters had been
fully considered
mid-suffolk members of the overview of
scrutiny committee
praised the in-house service whilst baby
district council members
expressed concerns around some aspects
of the external contract in their
district
members also considered that communities
are more likely to volunteer for litter
picks than the like with an in-house
service
the committee resolved to recommend to
cabinets that option to
be pursued and that further work be
carried out to develop the key
performance indicators
and contract management also the option
for
the local authority trading company be
retained as an option to be considered
in the future
these resolutions of the overview and
scrutiny committee are set out
as recommendations to cabinet on page
five of the agenda papers
thank you chair thank you councillor
councilman all i would add
to councillor wellam's introduction is
that we were very
fortunate in that we had two contrasting
experiences
uh with option one being as we are so we
examined
the situation as it currently is in
public realm
service option two describes the
in-house operation currently being
operated by
mid-suffolk uh so the experience of
mid-suffolk members was invaluable at
that point
option three is an outsourced service as
is currently held in baber with an
external contract
so we had the option to look at options
one two and three from direct experience
this was not
hypothetical um option four was
interesting
but uh with the time frame involved in
a year to set up either a new outsourced
contract
or to set up a latko the committee felt
very strongly
that there wasn't sufficient time to do
that properly and
the mid-suffolk option two was probably
not only probably was definitely the
right way to go
i don't think there's anything more can
be added to that the minute itself
describes some of the various arguments
but uh i think you have the
the thrust of it there thank you
thank you counselor um right members of
the cabinets
are there any particular questions you
wish to ask either the
the chairs of uh overview and scrutiny
um
or do you just want to move on to the
main report when we can take into
account
the points that they have raised in in
their report
does anyone have any questions that they
wish to ask
at this stage
and if that's the case um
that nobody wishes to ask any questions
i'll just
thank that the two joint chairs and and
the the view and scrutiny committee for
the work it's done um they've provided a
very thorough report
and um uh i note the uh
the comment about the uh keeping open
the option of the
the latch which we will obviously
discuss later
um and i know it's something that uh
what
when we were briefed on on this paper
that the two cabinets
were open to that suggestion as well so
so that's good
so moving on then to um item six
which is um the future delivery model
for public realm
um it's paper bca 1964 for baber
and um i'd like to firstly to
ask councillor malvisi to introduce that
before asking
councillor fleming to introduce the
corresponding paper for midsuffoci
thank you very much mr chairman it gives
me great pleasure to present
this very in-depth report concerning the
delivery of public realm services in
baber district
originally presented to cabinet in june
um it was felt that it needed a more
in-depth analysis
and the establishing of a business case
um just in case people don't appreciate
what is involved in public realm
services
public realm takes care of the
countryside
ground maintenance litter bins amenity
areas parks and open spaces
the street scene highway verges
uh maintenance on behalf of suffolk
county council
playgrounds public conveniences and that
means
unlocking locking the the lose um
on a daily basis so there'd be daily
checks
car parks and that only involves ground
maintenance
and cleansing in june we considered
four options to stay as we are
but we can't really stay as we are
because the contract is coming to an end
and we would have to go out to tender
for a new service contract
so that would sort of put us in limbo
for 12 to 18 months
bring the service delivery in-house
alongside mid-suffolk now that's an
interesting option
it would increase service standards
provide
more flexibility thus enabling us to
move forward on our evolving
biodiversity action plan
and i think that's the really for me
that's the very
interesting and exciting aspect of it it
would build on the skill sets
of mid suffolk it would build on their
experience
and their service levels the third
option
would be to outsource again that would
need
need tendering the time involved would
be 12 to 18 months it would be costly
you'd have to put interim alternative
arrangements in place
not not the path that i would go down
and the fourth
is establish a wholly owned trading
company
which is something to be considered once
we've bedded in
i i believe with the joint in-house
service
consequently i'm very pleased and very
proud um to represent the assistant
director cassandra clements and her team
and thank her and her team and the eelga
that's the east of england local
government association for their robust
and in-depth analysis of our public
realm service delivery
thank you thank you carlson rbc
um i'd now like to pass to councillor
fleming to introduce paper mca 1973
the mid-suffolk paper yes
thank you thank you very much and i
won't um
dwell um very long because i think um
counselor mal vici
has introduced the paper um very clearly
um i personally am very pleased that we
are
i hope going for option the option
of bringing all of the public realm work
in-house
under baber and mid-suffolk's joint
management i think this will work much
better
and i just like to i think now that we
have our diverse
biodiversity actions um coming
out i think it will enable us to deliver
these much more efficiently
and cohesively moving forward
um so i'm looking forward to this
new working i hope that it all goes
through smoothly today and um all being
well we should start to transition in
november when the
current contract that baba has with um
ivesko
runs out at the end of october um i'd
just like to add that i
i would like to thank the scrutiny and
overview committee um chaired by
councillor wellam for the excellent work
that they did
in looking at um the options and making
recommendations for us so
so thank you keith for that um so
with that um and my thanks also of
course to
um sandra clements and her team for
the hard work um and a lot of work it is
that has gone into making this possible
so
um thank you all very much
thank you councillor fleming um now we
have the the main papers um which on
pages seven to fourteen
and uh we also have the confidential
papers
um uh beyond that which include
transformation options and the business
case
so um if you have any questions
on the the main papers then then please
ask them now but
um bear in mind if if your questions are
the business case
then then we will have to move to
confidential session
so um may i ask any of the members
of the baby cabinet if you have any
questions at this point
and mid suffolk cabinet
do any of you have any questions at
councillor whitehead
yes um could we have confirmed or
otherwise my understanding that the
councils
can offer their in-house services to
parish councils
without the need for a lactico
cassandra
good morning chen um yes on councillor
whitehead's question we absolutely can
still offer services out to parish
councils
and there's still um elements of
devolution that we'd like to talk about
with those
town and parish councils that have shown
interest previously
thank you thank you um actually
before we uh go any further into this i
have forgotten one thing
and that is um we've had proposals from
baber and mid suffolk
um i'm happy to second uh councillor
malvisi
for uh from the baby perspective um may
i have a second
from mid suffolk for the mid suffolk
report please
i'm sorry um who's i am
proposing i'm happy to say that yes
is it that council having him yeah yeah
the council having him second thank you
uh councillor ebern you have a question
um thank you very much chair and thank
you very much for allowing me to ask her
a question um and i i just would if
i can add my thanks to i think that's a
really excellent piece of work
um and i think it it kind of in a way
that
shows a good kind of blueprint let's say
for for future types of projects
but my question um czar i i note
um in mid suffolk's case there's there's
you know many volunteers involved and i
i know
you know there's volunteer hours but i
wonder if we can calculate at some point
how much money this has effectively
saved us
and secondly other plans to
market this service more widely
because i know that many parish councils
use different companies for similar
services that
that new um if this is approved the new
joint combined team
could offer and and lastly if i may i'm
a little bit concerned about
the possibility for a trading company in
the future
because i wouldn't want um the people
that work in this service that on the
mid suffix sides
are really fantastic um staff working in
that service i wouldn't want them to be
under the cloud
of a um another change um
soon in the future thank you ever so
much chair for allowing me to answer
questions
thank you
can anyone pick up on that
can you respond i think we can yes thank
you councillor
a few questions so um i with the
volunteers absolutely and i think that's
really
great to be able to show what actually
the cost of volunteering is
and there's lots of really good formulas
out there to use so we can certainly
we can certainly show that and just to
say that volunteers is an area that i'd
really like to expand across
both districts and there is a really
good um blueprint to use your phrase
in both districts that we could we could
work on and
finally on the marketing services more
widely
and that's absolutely an aspiration of
mine and what i would like to do
is get the teams settled in um and
our service standards across the
district up
first before we commit to that but
certainly once that's in place
um i would like to go out to town and
parish councils and and some other you
know potentially schools
in the area and to offer our services
out to those as well
so the um the only difference really
between the in-house team and the latco
is that there's only a certain level
of income that you can achieve if you're
still in an in-house service
but i don't see as getting anywhere
close to that threshold just by
helping our town and parish councils so
certainly that is an aspiration of mind
to do that when the time is right
thank you very much for that thank you
guys
council of field do you have a question
yes uh i did have one around the latko
which i think you've just about answered
just then but the in
paragraph 10 it talks about the quality
impact assessment
saying that it's not required at this
stage i was just sort of questioning
isn't once you've made this decision any
any
uh equality impacts um set in stone
and therefore should that not be done at
this time
question ter would you like me to
answer yes please yeah um you're
absolutely right councillor feel that
an eqia will be needed um however one
wasn't done
at this point as we were unsure which
option
baby district council would want to go
forward with as soon as we have an
answer on that we will develop a full
eqia
in response to what the new service will
look like
but does that give you the ability still
to to
change anything that should fall foul of
the
eia at that time yes so because we're so
uh so close to the start of this that
really we really are starting from stage
one at that point so as soon as a
decision is made
on whatever option we want to go forward
we'll make sure
that the service provision is designed
in that way so if
we were to go forward with the office of
recommendation of option two
and it is entirely flexible so we can
absolutely design that service
to meet all the needs of our residents
thank you thank you councillor fleming
did you want to
come back on that um
no but i just wanted to raise them a
point if i made chairman
um i would just like maybe for the
benefit of everyone
for officers to clarify the
makeup and role of the environment
programme board
and particularly going forward what role
will this board play
and to what extent will members
particularly cabinet members
have involvement with it
thank you cass can you answer that
sure so if i uh give a brief update on
what the
programme board is and uh potentially um
arthur charvonia may want to come in
about the council-wide
boards so the environment board is one
of a number of boards that the council
run that look after predominantly
programmes and projects but sometimes
other activities of the council
so it's it's what we'd consider our
business as usual work
and it ensures that we uh are doing
everything that we should towards our
corporate outputs
and it manages the monitoring and
evaluation of those projects
to make sure that um we are spending our
budgets wisely
in order to achieve our strategies and
our corporate output so there are a
number of boards
in place to make sure we do that and
they have themes and off the top of my
head i'm sure i'm not going to be able
to name them all but there's a customer
transformation board
an environment programme board a joint
local plan program board
a housing board and and a people board i
believe
are all of them on a growth board excuse
me and so they are all chaired by either
arthur charvonio or kathy nixon
they all have two or three assistant
directors sitting on them
and they also have project support as
well as the relevant corporate managers
for those areas so those people look
after
and the range of programs and projects
within those themed areas along with the
assistance of
finance and communications
thank you cass right um
if there are no further questions on i
still have a question
oh sorry sorry casper fleming um
yes i just on the program
boards i'm particularly interested in
the environment programme board
i'm a little concerned that this is
completely
officer-led and that the cabinet members
will not
have sight of the forward plan or the
agendas
or the minutes of any meetings are these
confidential
john perhaps if i can assist you in that
and just give some
reassurance um so then they're not
officer led in the sense that
you're absolutely right very few of them
actually have counsellors sitting on
them
but they're absolutely not officer-led
in the sense that the what determines
the program
entirely is determined by the two
cabinets um so really these are
as cassandra clements described these
are the mechanisms behind the scenes by
which
as officers we make sure we're
delivering what it is that you've all
asked us
to deliver and the linkages are as you
would expect
so for the environment board the linkage
would be from
cassandra into each of the the cabinet
members for environment
and as cassandra described earlier each
of these program boards are very
deliberately aligned to
your six strategic priorities plus an
extra two one for people
to make sure that we're doing everything
that we need to be doing in relation to
our staffing
and the other for the joint local plan
because whilst planning isn't
one of your six uh strategic priorities
clearly it's very important in terms of
delivery of the local plan
grant thank you i just wonder whether um
going forward here because there's so
much
really new happening with particularly
with environment
that's my role but but in general
whether it wouldn't be helpful
um it would be helpful for me speaking
for myself to um
just have sight of the um agenda and to
have a little bit more connection with
the board
so i'll leave it at that thank you very
much
okay councilman malvisi
um it's a point of clarification really
um
following on from councillor fleming
my understanding then of let's take as
an example the environment program
board that is what i would refer
to as an executive management board
where the executives who are actually
executing
the uh the instructions from cabinet or
portfolio holders
get together and report back on where
they're at
what they need what they don't need how
it's running how it's not running
um and therefore i suppose
if councillor fleming agrees with me
that we should
as portfolio holders for always as the
example environment
um that we get a report back every time
the
program board meets question mark
yes i mean i i'd be as you described it
is exactly right
um so exactly that in terms of this is
where we execute
your instruction so to speak um in terms
of reporting back to cabinet members
i wouldn't want to um impose a structure
on you that said you will all get a
report back
after every program board i think that's
a matter for each cabinet member
to determine what frequency they would
like but absolutely the connection is
expected to be there
between the program boards and the
cabinet members that is that main
linkage
just to give you some reassurance um
whilst the program boards
uh came into existence around about i
think probably around about march
time um that covered thing got in the
way so the
the environment board is only i think
met now three times so these are very
much a new structure if you like
that we have in place the only one
that's been running much longer is that
is the joint local program
board uh which has slightly different
arrangements but
absolutely as you described but i think
it's probably a case of each assistant
director liaising with their respective
cabinet members to what frequency works
for you
rather than us saying here you go here's
a report every month or every time the
the board's met
but it is exactly that it's progress
against the projects that you have
agreed and signed off and with funding
for could
i could i possibly suggest then that um
if we think of things along the chain of
command
a chain is made up of links so if you
leave the link
open and that would be
not reporting back then the chain of
command is weakened
so maybe if program boards do report
back to their portfolio holders
it would actually strengthen the chain
of command
yes absolutely absolutely and the
linkage is there already
um so just to get so i'm slightly
concerned that this has come up only
because this is going off at a tangent
but it's but i'm glad it has come up in
terms of it provides us the opportunity
to make sure those linkages as you say
are there
the linkage should be there already not
so much to the board
but to your respective assistant
director through your routine
uh meetings uh in terms of briefings but
we can make sure that program board
activity forms part of
that conversation i suspect it already
does already
without the words programme board being
attached to it if you see what i mean
but we can make that
more formal i'd like to thank the chair
and both cabinets
for um enabling me to ask that question
yeah
that's fine it was uh worth uh having
that uh digression and getting that
clarified but
um uh moving back to the
uh the actual paper we have in front of
us um
uh obviously uh no further questions but
uh we will move into debate now um
but firstly can anyone uh let me know if
they wish to talk about the confidential
paper
um in which case uh i will move into
confidential session but um
if if not then um
we will debate the the main paper um
cass did you want to say something
thank you chair yes just before we move
on could i just introduce
my two guests that are here with me
today of course yeah
thank you yes thank you so i have
mark ms and colin taylor here with me
today
uh who are available to answer questions
as well so
these are the two consultants that have
helped us greatly
in both the options appraisal earlier in
the year and
in writing the business case that's
before you today
and they've been exceptionally helpful
they've worked very closely with
our teams and uh very much a lot of the
thanks go to them
for the detail that's in this report so
they're available
for everybody to ask questions too as
well okay
thank you thank you right um
so uh i think we've got um
two separate recommendations um uh one
for midsuffoc
discussed differently does anyone from
babel wish to comment on
um uh what we have to do which is
effectively choose one of these
options um and uh obviously
you'll have heard from overview and
scrutiny that
they recommend bringing in-house and
indeed we have discussed this i know in
in in the briefing and come to a similar
conclusion does anyone from baber wish
to
to comment on on that option um
uh at this stage
and for mid-suffolk um it's to continue
with the in-house service
so again does anyone from mid-suffolk
wish to comment on that
does anyone have any questions they
would like to ask
on the the confidence council busby
good morning i i just have a couple of
concerns one is that we're setting up a
like an organization if you like which
will be in competition with suffolk
county council's
vertas i'm just wondering whether
whether that's perceived to be a good
thing or not bearing in mind we're
supposed to be working a lot closer with
all of the councils and then the second
thing is that uh
when we looked at bringing in building
services into
in-house the costings were
woefully inadequate in terms of we
underestimated a lot of the costs uh how
sure are we that we've got the costings
right this time
thank you cass
do you want to pick that up or sure
thank you councillor buzzfeed so um if
the
cabinet decide to go ahead with the
lacco option
then you're absolutely correct and that
it would be in direct competition to
someone like
bertas and suffolk county council um
so that that is one of the um
cons i guess of that uh option which is
detailed in the paper there's pros and
cons set out for all of the options in
there
um and one of the reasons that it's not
the offer officer recommendation is that
it is a very hard um sector to get into
especially when you are so small so the
the likes of bertha
the likes of landscape management
and company id verdi are all very large
companies
and and so the ability to infiltrate
those kind of contracts certainly at
that size is quite difficult which is
why
at this point that wasn't the officer
recommendation though i'd certainly take
into account
overview and scrutiny's recommendation
to keep it open for the future
um in terms of building services um this
has been spoken about a lot
um both overview and scrutiny and uh
unofficially
or informally excuse me as well um
and actually we see that as a really
good lesson to have learned from that
so um everything that happened with
building services we've got the
advantage of learning from and
mark and colin who are with me today
have had
full and open discussions with our
finance team
uh we've had really good information
back from ida verdi about their costs
and so we are confident that the figures
that we have included
are correct however i'm very happy to
hand over to
either marco collin to give um a bit
more detailed answer about what we've
covered in those finances
i believe colin will come in on that
point
colin good morning everyone um yeah just
to
offer some reassurance around that um
costing side
we as cassandra said we work very very
closely
with the um finance team
and i have to say my experience probably
one of the best experiences i've had of
working with a finance team very very
cooperative
very open very supportive um
so that was really helpful mark's
experience
from the commercial sector has enabled
him to engage really
productively with id verdi he speaks
their language
and we got really good information from
them as far as possible
and i think overall as consultants what
we've done with this
with with this scenario is is
be extremely cautious we were aware of
your history particularly with the
building services and
as cash said um that's a you know a
learning experience for everyone
including us
um and we've seen plenty of these in in
other authorities that we've worked
within
so we took a very cautious very prudent
approach
um and if you look at you know
particular areas of sensitivity
like the impact of bringing staff in
from a commercial contractor onto local
government pension scheme
and on to standard council terms and
conditions
we we've we've tried to be as
comprehensive as possible about modeling
the impact of of that
going forward i think in conclusion
as consultants the worst thing we can do
is paint a
sort of overly rosy picture for you that
leads you to make a
an informed decision so we would
actually
as consultants rather present a a
very prudent and and cautious
set of numbers that say
in essence this is this is the worst
case scenario and actually i think
within the model
there's probably some going forward in
terms of productivity and
and and you know sweating your assets
and getting more
uh bang for your buck i think there's
actually some potential in there
for you okay so i come back in john
and did at any point we have discussions
with vertis about
working jointly
no we haven't had a discussion with any
external contractor about
working jointly okay
okay thank you colin um counselor
brewster
thank you mr chair um yeah from the
mid-south like angle
i have to say that i'm really really
pleased that we are looking at the
in-house model because um from the
mid-southic angle
most of us know exactly how that has
worked for us
and it it a phone call
gets very rapid response i have to say
and
and uh that's been the same right the
way
since uh i've been on council
and i think it probably can't be um
superseded um
we have a really good team there at the
moment and i suspect that as we
um get the enlarged team
that things will move forward um to it
to an
even greater level and and that's to be
very much welcomed um
on on the latko front um
yeah i know the amount of business that
is is around that's
that's um doing this work it it
it is probably a difficult one to get
into to get the the really big
jobs i suspect um but
that's not saying that i don't think
it's a good idea
and i just think that we need when we
look at it to be quite cautious in our
approach on it
and that is i think
really all i want to say there but um i
do welcome this this move
thank you council whitehead
thank you chair um i mean this is more
of a request than a question i guess but
without going to any great expense i'd
like to see both
like see the new combined service having
our branding
clearly visible so the residents of both
districts can see the councils working
together
providing these great services from
their council tax
yeah i'd echo that yeah thank you
um i've got uh a question actually um
obviously i think um uh from
the baby cabinet perspective i know um
how how my colleagues feel at
bringing in house and and working
to provide a joint in-house service
across the both districts is
is the way that uh we would prefer to go
um
and i don't want to go into the specific
details um to avoid going into
uh confidential session but looking at
the acquisition of um the capital spend
and acquisition of
of fleet assets um
just some clarification the the pages in
uh further down the agenda pack talk
about
some assets being shared between the two
districts
um but there are some others that have
been uh bought specifically by bay but
does that mean that there are uh certain
vehicles which will operate only in one
district or another
or or is it the intention that all
vehicles will be shared across both
districts
so it's most likely that there will be
some vehicles that do work only in one
district
um simply because they'll be based on
route so they'll be allocated to a route
and the route would be allocated to
members of staff so it's much more
likely that those kind of vehicles
would end up staying what we are going
to look at is making sure that we don't
create an invisible boundary that that
makes us less effective
on the district boundaries so there can
be some routes that will go across
district and therefore um the vehicle
may
technically belong to baber and work in
mid-suffolk or vice versa
and then as as the report says there
will be some other assets probably
the more and the more expensive ones so
we don't end up buying one for each
council and it's sitting there for
hours a day we'll look at um combining
those so we can
have uh shifts on those so they can be
used across both districts um
whilst that does bring the lifespan of
that vehicle down
a little it's much more effective than
buying two vehicles um
one for each council so that's the very
large vehicles like your
large sweepers and hot washes and things
like that
thanks guys and and that brings me on to
my next
question which is the um the sweeper
which is going to need replacing um
because it's coming to the end of life
um and uh you're probably aware that
there have been some
questions over uh clearance of country
lanes where the
uh soil and and um vegetation is built
up in the middle and the current sweeper
can't
deal with that uh is that something we
can look at in
in terms of a replacement vehicle being
able to do that because neither
we nor nor the county council seem to be
able to
to deal with these roads and um apart
from being a hazard to cyclists uh
unless you have an suv your car will get
grounded on on this
absolutely so when we look to replace
the sweeper it will certainly be of a
better model and grade without doubt
and what we will have to do is because
i'm not sure
any sweeper can deal with the state that
some of the roads are in currently
what we might have to do is look at a
schedule of work that goes alongside for
some of the
um worse affected areas because they may
need some
hand clearance or some other mechanical
clearance first to get on top of them
but a new sweeper absolutely would be
able to keep on top of those areas much
better
okay thank you councillor morley
um i've got a question for when we move
into
a private session thank you chair
right okay um
it's probably a good point that we we do
that
or vote to do that now um we will
obviously have to
to come back to public section for the
the final
um vote on the recommendations but
uh i think probably at this stage we
will
move into private session um so
therefore
for item seven on the agenda um we need
to consider whether pursuant to part one
of schedule 12a of the
government act 1972 the public should be
excluded from the meeting for the
business specified below on the grounds
that if the public were present during
this item it is likely that there would
be disclosure to them of exempt
information as indicated against the
item
the author of the report proposed to be
considered in part two of the agenda
is satisfied that the public interest in
maintaining the exemption
outweighs the public interest in this
information
so can we take a vote on whether to
move into a confidential session to
discuss
the uh part two papers
i'm proposing that may i have a second
i'll second it thank you castle rbc
right um unless and uh rather than go
through a role called vote unless anyone
uh has any uh uh uh
reason why we shouldn't then i propose
we move into the confidential session to
discuss the part two papers
okay can we switch off the
thank you and welcome back to the the
public session of
this simultaneous cabinet meeting right
we're now
um going to move into voting on the
recommendations
um now the first recommendation for
baber
is that uh the cabinet takes a decision
um i think we have uh come to that
decision and that is
option two um to
uh bring the service in-house uh do we
also wish to add
the um uh the the recommendation from
overview and scrutiny that we
can in the future at least keep the
option open
of a trading company which is option
four
yes that's what i thought the way that
we were going here so for baber then
um i think we we can move to
a vote on on that recommendation then
claire
thank you chair so when i call your
names if you can say four against or
abstain
councillor busby cool councillor davis
councillor davis
he is there okay i'll come back to him
in a moment
councillor melvisi four
councillor osborne four
councillor parker four council award
four councillor davis
paul thank you it's unanimous chair
thank you right um for mid-suffolk then
uh the recommendation is that uh you
wish to continue
with the the current in-house service um
and do you also wish to uh as overview
and scrutiny has has recommended
uh keep open the option of of option for
the the trading company
uh councillor whitehead and strictly
speaking that option is open anyway
whether we consider it or not
that's probably yes
okay then uh claire can you take the the
mid suffolk vote please
thank you chair councillor brewster
four councillor byrne
councillor flatman boar councillor
fleming
councillor gould four councillor
hattingham four
councillor morley four
councillor richardson four councillor
whitehead
four
thank you chair that's unanimous thank
you
well thanks very much everyone and and
thanks to to colin and mark for
for joining us and and and helping out
with the questions
um that concludes today's simultaneous
cabinet meeting
at the next meeting is on the 5th of
october
at 2 30. thank you very much everyone
bye
you